we're back with the ever so talented and
friend of the show sutton foster and
we're crafting oh yeah
you would turn to crafting you know
throughout your life
definitely and so and and i've used it
as a tool for myself but now i use it as
a tool to bond with my daughter teach me
teach all of us what are we making today
okay well this is totally inspired by my
daughter she wanted to make little
presents for her classmates she's in
pre-k and so she was like let's make
something for everyone and i'm like
so i started to panic and then i thought
well what if we made everyone like
little cards like little holiday cards
and so that's what we're doing so we
have little canvases
um pieces of paper lots of options for
and you can basically do whatever you
want this is sort of the goal is
something that's sort of cute paper
little circles little googly eyes
because who's who doesn't like a googly
eyes
and i am i think i might be a human
googly eye
i love to use this is modge podge which
is basically just like you can't mess it
up you can you can put it on the bottom
you can put it on the top and it always
dries clear which is
pretty great for any type of crafting
project i didn't know it tried clear oh
yeah so you can't really like mess up so
even if it like glops on or anything so
you can do anything you want so i like
to just and then you just kind of get
messy and go for it and you can glob it
on you can put anything on you can do
you can cut out different types of hats
and then the cool thing about kids too
about well my daughter too i'm just
putting on a background because you know
why not she's more imaginative than
anything that i could come up with
because i'm like okay here this is what
we're going to do and she's like no i'm
doing this other thing and she's cutting
things out and then she decided to i i
have all these like
little i thought oh i have like little
stickers of letters and stuff and next
thing i know she's taking all the o's
because she's like they look like
ornaments and i was like
they do yes and she's created this whole
motif with all the o's yeah and i'm like
yeah that's better than anything i could
have come up with so you kind of let
them sort of you you put up put a bunch
of stuff out and then you sort of let
them go crazy
but you can cut stuff out too and cut
any type of shape out but then these are
like these little stampers which is
really cool
which i've never seen now i'm like
wait super excited about this because
i know look at how nicely it's a perfect
car
oh
wow i know they're so cute all right
we've got a snowman going on here right
can you mod podge over it yeah really
yeah mine are really
this has a cute little hat they're
really ticking me off because they're
not sticking and no you just go crazy
i'm i'm having words with my snowman
over here
like listen buddy
you're oh no oh oh there we go you're
doing great
great oh no
the thing with crafting or any type of
crap
it looks fantastic look at the googly
eyes
the googly eyes look nuts can anyone get
it
again
it just has to be like fun
and it's just something that you're
doing for fun and then you can give it
to give it to somebody and they're like
hey look at that this is so cool emily
is going to have
so much incredible guidance and
wonderment we do a lot of fun stuff
together i i can imagine it's pretty
great
well
and she inspires me every day you know
i'm just i'm incredibly i'm just really
proud of her and i'm proud to be her mom
well i will say your tenacity
um
to create this family is one of the most
beautiful things i've ever read in a
book and i celebrate your journey and
everybody will
um when they read the kind words and the
beautiful journey you were sharing with
everybody in your book okay
i'm almost done here that looks good
i'm gonna i want to put some sprinkles
so yeah also literally
glitter
candy
this is exciting because glitter
glitter's not allowed in our house
because it's so messy but here okay
there you go
there okay there you go
your candy cane's gonna get a lesson in
mud
it's so cute
you know
it doesn't suck as badly as i thought it
but
it's like you can go to the store and
you can buy craft stuff but there's so
many things that you can use around the
house as well in magazines you can cut
out colors you can cut out anything
oh yes any of it like there's always
little things you can find so well i
think also just the ritual of crafting
with your family loved ones or
by yourself to
make beautiful things and the way that
you pour yourself into your pieces
they must have so much soul depth and
meaning they do they're filled with a
lot of things a lot of energy a lot of
different kinds of energy but mostly
hopefully a lot of love i think it's
great advice also to like
like i turned to acting a lot when i was
growing up and i felt lucky to have that
like productive healthy cathartic
channel so that you can work out stuff
that isn't easy to deal with and make
something and channel it and sutton i
think you've shown us and taught us some
really powerful lessons in your book
about the way that you conduct that
through your crafting thank you
thank you
um okay
please grab your copy of hook how
crafting saved my life in stores now and
catch sutton in the music man i think
i'm gonna
really
i'm so excited to see it i can't
even broadway starting december 20th
[Music]
you